THANK SENATE COMMITTEE ON
ELECTIONS AND CONSTITUTIONAL
AMENDMENTS WILL COME TO ORDER
GOOD MORNING IN RESPONSE TO COPE
WITH NINETEEN A VIRGIN SEE INTO
PROTECT THE PUBLIC LEGISLATORS
AND EMPLOYEES WE MUST LIMIT
NONESSENTIAL GATHERINGS IN HERE
TO SOCIAL DISTANCING AND FACE
COVERING GUIDELINES AND
COMPLIANCE WITH THOSE ORDERS THE
SENATE HAS MADE NECESSARY
ADJUSTMENTS TO NORMAL PRACTICES
IN ORDER TO ENSURE THAT THE
PUBLIC ENTITIES HAVE ACCESS TO
THE LEGISLATIVE PROCESS ROLE IN
OUR COMMITTEE HEARING IN THE-
STREET BUILDING. I ASK ALL
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE TO BE
PRESENT IN THE ROOM TWENTY ONE
HUNDRED SO WE CAN ESTABLISH A
QUORUM AND BEGIN OUR HEARING TO
ALLOW THE PUBLIC ACCESS WITH
ADMITTED MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
INTO THE HEARING ROOM EXTENT
THAT SOCIAL DISTANCING
REQUIREMENTS ALLOW WILL BE USING
TELECONFERENCE SERVICES FOR
THOSE INDIVIDUALS WHO WISH TO
TESTIFY. TODAY FOR ALL
INDIVIDUALS WISHING TO PROVIDE
PUBLIC COMMENT THE PARTICIPANT
TOLL FREE NUMBER AND ACCESS CODE
IS POSTED ON THE COMMITTEE
WEBSITE. TODAY'S PARTICIPANT
NUMBER IS EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN. TWO
TWO SIX EIGHT ONE SIX THREE. AND
THE ACCESS CODE IS SEVEN THREE
SIX. TWO EIGHT THREE THREE. FOR
DETAILED INSTRUCTIONS ON HOW THE
TELECONFERENCES WORKS. WITH YOU
FOR THE SENATE. OR ARE COMMITTEE
WEBSITE. WHEN WE MOVED PUBLIC
COMMENT YOU'LL BE PROMPTED BY A
MODERATOR TO DIAL ONE AND THEN
ZERO FOR SUPPORT AND OPPOSITION.
PRESSES ONLY ONE. AND WAIT
PATIENTLY FOR AN OPERATOR TO
ASSIGN YOU A LINE NUMBER. THIS
CAN BE A SHORT WAIT ONCE YOU
RECEIVE YOUR LINE NUMBER YOU'LL
WAIT IN THE QUEUE FOR THE
MODERATE YOUR CALL YOUR LINE
NUMBER. AT THAT TIME YOU'LL BE
ON MUTED AND YOU READY TO
ADDRESS THE COMMITTEE. PLEASE
NOTE THAT IN ORDER FOR US TO
HEAR YOU CLEARLY AND AVOID
ACOUSTIC FEEDBACK YOU MUST USE
THE DEVICE YOU'RE WATCHING-
PRIOR TO GIVING TESTIMONY OVER
THE PHONE. IT'S IMPORTANT WE
HEAR FROM YOU. AND THANK YOU FOR
YOUR PATIENCE. ALL MAINTAIN
DECORUM DURING THE HEARING AS
CUSTOMARY. WE HAVE ONE BILL AND
OUR AGENDA TODAY. I WILL FOR BY
SEN BACKER BEFORE WE HEAR THAT
BILL THAT'S ESTABLISH A QUORUM
CONSULT WHEN YOU CALL THE ROLL
PLEASE. GLAZER HERE. GLAZER HERE
NEIL. SEN HERE HERTZBERG LEYVA
HERE LEYVA HERE NEWMAN HERE
NEWMAN HERE SO WE HAVE A QUORUM
SO WE'LL BEGIN WITH OUR FIRST
ITEM ON THE AGENDA SB FIVE OH
FOUR BY SENATOR CENTER BACKER
BACKWARDS CENTER BACKER MICHAEL
WELCOME YOU CAN USE THE PODIUM
OR THE PLACE YOU WANT TO
PRESENTS AND YOU CAN BEGIN. AT
WHENEVER YOU'RE READY. A GOOD
MORNING MEMBERS SB FIVE OH FOUR
CONTINUES TO BE A BIPARTISAN
VOTER REGISTRATION MEASURE
SPONSORED BY STATE CLERKS AND
ELECTION OFFICIALS IS BACK FOR
CONCURRENCE AFTER SIMPLY
AMENDMENTS THIS IS YOUR STATE
REQUESTED URGING MEMBERS TO BE
TAKEN IN THE ASSEMBLY WE SHOULD
TWO THINGS TO CLEAN UP- VOTE BY
MAIL PROCEDURES DO THEY START
PASSAGE OF AB THIRTY SEVEN.
WHICH MAKE CALIFORNIA THE LATEST
A TO PERMANENTLY MAIL 100% OF
REGISTERED VOTERS ABOUT. THE
FIRST CHANGE MOVES A QUESTION
FOR THE VOTER REGISTRATION CARD
APPLICATION THAT SAYS DO YOU
WANT TO BE A PERMANENT VOTE BY
MAIL VOTER. THIS IS NO LONGER
NEEDED SINCE CALIFORNIA
REGISTERED VOTERS ARE NOW BUT BY
NO VOTERS ALL OF THEM. THE
SECOND RELATEDLY REMOVES THE
REQUIREMENT. THAT REQUIRES THE
COUNTY ELECTION OFFICIAL TO MAIL
OUT AN APPLICATION TO BE A VOTE
BY MAIL VOTER AGAIN THIS IS NOT
NEEDED. SINCE ALL CALIFORNIA
RESERVOIRS ARE NOW VOTE BY MAIL
YOU RECEIVE THE BALLOT AND DO
NOT NEED TO APPLY. THESE CHANGES
ARE URGENT IN THE JUNE PRIMARY
WILL NOT ONLY SAVE OUR COUNTY
ELECTION OFFICIALS MONEY IN TIME
THAT WILL REDUCE VOTER
CONFUSION. I RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST YOUR CONTINUED SUPPORT
WITH AN AYE VOTE. THANK SENATOR
BAKER NINERS YOU HAVE TO LEAD
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT BEFORE WE
GET TO THEM. LET ME MENTION THAT
ARE THOSE WHO ARE FAMILIAR WITH
THEIR HEARING KNOW THAT THE
CHAIR CAN SET. TIME LIMITS ARE
OUR TRADITIONAL TIME LIMITS HAVE
BEEN TWENTY MINUTES ON EACH
pSIDE- THE LEAD PRESENTERS SET TO
NOT. EAT AND THAT'S WILL DO FOR
SUPPORT AND OPPOSITION. AND THEN
WILL NOT LEAD TO YOUR TO
WITNESSES AND SUPPORT I HAVE IT
IT DECK COURTNEY. BAILEY
ANALYSTS WITH THE SACRAMENTO
COUNTY. AND ERIC GARRIS WITH THE
SECRETARY OF STATE'S OFFICE OR
AND OR YOU WISH TO GO IN. THE
OTHER ONES OKAY LET'S LET'S
BEGIN WITH THE SECRETARY OF
STATE- ERIC GARRISON. AT A
HEARING THE RUMOR ON THE ON THE
PHONE LINES. ON THE PHONE OKAY-
ERIC. YOU CAN BEGIN. WARMEST
GOOD MORNING HERE LATER SENATORS
. YEARS ON BEHALF OF SECTARIAN
DOCTOR WEBER SUPPORT OF THE
SENATE BILL BIBLE FOR. A PERSON
TO START BY THANKING CENTER
BACKROOM STAFF- COMMITTEE STAFF
AND LEADERSHIP STAFF. WORKING
WITH OFFICE NOT THE MINUTES THIS
BE POSSIBLE FOR YOU TO SIMPLY
ELIMINATE REQUIREMENTS EXISTING
LAW THAT MAKE REFERENCE TO THE
QUESTION VOTE BY MAIL
APPLICATION. THE REASON IS THAT
THE BIBLE FOR SIMPLY ATTEMPT TO
MINIMIZE ANY CONFUSION. THAT MAY
BE EXPRESSED BY VOTERS AT THE
REQUIRED TO MAKE BEST PERCENT.
BURKE JUST APPLICATIONS FOR
WHERE THEY NEED TO APPLY FOR A
BILL BY MAIL APPLICATION WERE TO
REMAIN. THANKS FOR YOUR TIME
TODAY AND SECRETARY REFLECT-
REQUEST ARRIVAL. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MISTER GARRIS WILL GO THEN
TO COURTNEY BAILEY CAN. NO LESS
FOR THE SACRAMENTO COUNTY
REGISTRAR. GOOD MORNING CHECK
LATER IN MY- OF THE- MY IS
COURTNEY BAILEY CANNELLA
REGISTER. VOTER FOR SACRAMENTO
COUNTY AND CO CHAIR OF THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF CLERKS
AND ELECTION OFFICIALS
LEGISLATIVE COMMITTEE. ON BEHALF
OF THE ASSOCIATION WE ARE
PLEASED TO SPONSOR AND SUPPORT
SENATE BILL FIVE OH FOUR. I
WOULD LIKE TO EXPRESS OUR
SINCEREST GRATITUDE TO SENATOR
BACKGROUND STAFF FOR THE
IMPORTANT WORK ON THIS BILL. SB
FIVE OH FOUR PROVIDE TIMELY
UPDATES TO ENSURE ALL ELIGIBLE
CITIZENS HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
VOTE IN CURRENT ELECTIONS. THIS
INCLUDES MORE ACCESS TO
CONDITIONAL VOTER REGISTRATION
FOR OUR MILITARY OVERSEAS
VOTERS. AND UPDATES TO OUR VOTER
FILE MAINTENANCE PROCEDURES.
THESE PROVISIONS WERE SHARED AT
THE INITIAL TESTIMONY ON THIS
BILL FROM MY COLLEAGUE IN TWENTY
TWENTY ONE. SINCE THAT TIME
ASSEMBLY BILL THIRTY SEVEN WHICH
CHAPTER WHICH PROVIDES FOR EVERY
ACTIVE REGISTERED VOTER IN THE
STATE. TO AUTOMATICALLY RECEIVE
A BALLOT IN THE MAIL FOR EVERY
ELECTION. WORKING CLOSELY WITH
SENATOR BACKERS OFFICE IT WAS
IMPORTANT TO ELIMINATE EXISTING
REQUIREMENTS THAT COULD POP
VOTER CONFUSION. THIS INCLUDES
ALLOWING COUNTIES TO REMOVE THE
VOTE BY MAIL APPLICATION FROM
THE COUNTY VOTER INFORMATION
GUIDE. WHICH IS ALREADY ALLOWED
FOR COUNTIES TO CONDUCT
ELECTIONS UNDER THE VOTERS
CHOICE ACT. AND UPDATING
CALIFORNIA'S VOTER REGISTRATION
FORMS. TO REMOVE THE PERMANENT
VOTE BY MAIL OPTION. ELIMINATING
CONFUSION FROM VOTERS AND
VOLUNTEERS OR STAFF TO HELP.
REGISTER VOTERS. IN A ENTIRETY
AS FIVE OH PER FOR A MORE AUTUMN
CROSS. TO IMPROVE FILE
MAINTENANCE MORE VOTING ACCESS
FOR MILITARY AND OVERSEAS
VOTERS. AND ELIMINATE OBSOLETE
REQUIREMENTS NOW THAT EVERY ACT
OF VOTER WILL RECEIVE A BALLOT
IN THE MAIL. ALL OF THESE
ATHLETES ARE GREAT FOR VOTERS
AND GREAT FOR EVERYONE INVOLVED
WHO WANT TO MAKE SURE VOTERS
HAVE ACCURATE ELECTION
INFORMATION LEADING UP TO THE
TWENTY TWENTY TO MID TERM
ELECTIONS. THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK WITH THE
OFF THE DAY AND WE RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH SCHATTEN'S BAILEY
CANALIS ALL RIGHT THAT'S THE TO
LEAD WITNESSES IN SUPPORT WE'RE
GONNA GO TO OTHER FOLKS WHO'D
LIKE TO SHARE THEIR- THEIR VIEWS
AND AT THIS POINT IN THAT AND
THE HEARING WE JUST ASK THAT YOU
GIVE YOUR NAME AFFILIATION AND
EDUCATION SUPPORT WE'RE GONNA.
STAY ON THE SUPPORT SIDE ANYONE
HERE IN ROOM TWENTY ONE HUNDRED
THAT WAS TESTIFYING IN SUPPORT.
SEE NO ONE LEAVING OUT OF THEIR
CHAIRS RUNNING OVER THE PHONE
LINES. AND ASKED THE- MODERATOR
IF THERE'S ANYBODY ON THE LINE
THAT WISHES TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT
WOULD YOU PLEASE ASK THEM. TO
WRITE A MUTANT CELLS. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIRMAN THE GENTLEMAN ON
THE PHONES TO COMMONSENSE.
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO ON YOUR
PHONE'S KEYPAD. AB ONE NUMBER
ONE THIS CALL STATE YOUR NAME
THE POLICE WHAT'S THE RECORDS
WHICH IMPRESSED ONE G. THE STOCK. MISTER CHAIRMAN FROM THERE IS
NOBODY KEEPING UP VERY GOOD
THANK YOU MODERATOR WE'RE GOING
TO NOW GO TO THE OPPOSITION
SIDE- THE OPPOSITION SIDE SO
WILL I DON'T HAVE A LEAD
OPPOSITION WITNESS SO WE'RE
GONNA OPEN IT UP HERE FIRST IN
ROOM TWENTY ONE HUNDRED IS OR
ANYONE HERE THAT WISH TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION- TO SB FIVE OH
FOUR. I'D SEEN ON WE'RE GONNA GO
TO THE PHONE LINES MODERATOR CAN
ASK IF THERE'S ANYBODY IN Q.
THAT WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION TO ASK BEFORE. FIVE
OF. FIVE OH FOUR. ONCE AGAIN A
COMMON IN OPPOSITION PRESS. ONE
ZERO SIX. RESEARCHER ONCE AGAIN
WE HAVE NOBODY INTRIGUED OKAY
VERY GOOD WE'RE GONNA BRING THE
MATTER BACK TO THE COMMITTEE FOR
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS MEMBERS
ANY QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS.
SENATOR SENATOR NEWMAN I'M GLAD
TO MOVE THE BILL OKAY ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS- AT CENTER
BACK WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE.
ARE STRICTLY ASK FOR AYE VOTE
YOU'RE MY FRIEND TERRIFIC WE
HAVE A MOTION BY SENATOR NEWMAN-
DO PASS- I GUESS AS WE GO TO THE
FLOOR OF THE SENATE RIGHT. FOR
THIS HEADS NEXT. OKAY THE-
CONSOLE WOULD CALL THE ROLL. THE
ON FILE ITEM ONE SB FIVE OH FOUR
BECKER THE MOTION IS THAT THE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER SPEAKING
OCCURRED IN. PLEASE HI PLEASE.
HI NIELSEN. NIELSEN I. HERTZBERG
HERTZBERG I. LEYVA LEYVA HI
NEWMAN ALL RIGHT NEWMAN I A
CENTER BACK HITS YOUR LUCKY DAY
THAT BILL IS A FIVE THANK YOU
AND THE SECRETARY OF STATE AND
ALL THOSE INVOLVED THE CLERKS
TO- TO GET THIS BILL FOR. IT TO
GET GET EVERYTHING TOGETHER AND
OF COURSE THANK YOU TO SCOTT AND
MARIA FROM OUR COMMITTEE
STAFFORD MAKING THIS ALL HAPPEN
AT SUCH SHORT ORDER THANK YOU TO
ALL THE INDIVIDUALS WHO
PARTICIPATED IN THE TEST IN THE
PUBLIC TESTIMONY TODAY IF YOU'RE
NOT ABLE TO TESTIFY WELCOME TO
SUBMIT YOUR COMMENTS IN WRITING
TO THE COMMITTEE. YOUR COMMENTS
SUGGESTIONS ARE IMPORTANT TO US
FOR ONE OF THE KLUGER TESTIMONY
IN THE OFFICIAL HEARING RECORD
THANK YOU AGAIN WE APPRECIATE
YOUR PARTICIPATION THANK YOU MY
COMMITTEE COLLEAGUES FOR JOINING
US IN THIS SHORT HEARING THIS
MORNING WITHOUT THE SENATE
COMMITTEE ELECTIONS AND
CONSTITUTIONAL AMENDMENTS IS A
JERK.